si es justamente el consejo el comité
supremo electoral el isk el que debe dar
a un ganador o dictaminar que debe haber
una segunda vuelta en estas elecciones
presidenciales y aún nos han pronunciado
acerca del resultado final por lo que
tocará esperar no sabemos hasta cuándo
lo que está claro es que la población
turca tiene la esperanza de que este
anuncio se produzca lo antes posible
Quizá en el día de hoy ahora mismo la
agencia gubernamental de noticias
hanadolu con un
99,3% aproximadamente del voto
contabilizado sigue dando a erdogan como
ganador con un poco más del 49% del
apoyo Mientras que el líder opositor que
mal que literó se situaría en cerca
aproximadamente del
45% por su parte la agencia privada anca
que también está haciendo un seguimiento
exhaustivo de este voto da unos
resultados ya similares Aunque en su
caso con casi la totalidad del
escrutinio estrecha una pequeña
diferencia con respecto al candidato y
actual presidente de hiperdogán y muy
brevemente ante esta incertidumbre
Cuáles han sido las reacciones
si las reacciones de ambos candidatos
receta hiper dogán ayer mismo dijo que
estaban liderando estas elecciones
también reivindicó que el parlamento lo
habían ganado cuando realmente los
escrutinios hasta el momento y los
resultados que tenemos preliminares no
le dan una mayoría absoluta algo que él
ayer sí que quiso reivindicar a la vez
que dijo que en caso de tener una
mayoría parlamentaria sería de lógica
que él también ganase estas elecciones
quitarol por su parte se refería a los
millones de votos aún no contabilizados
y ahora mismo la cuestión está en si el
tercer candidato sin anoán ya fuera de
estas elecciones por lo tanto ex
candidato A quién le va a dar el apoyo
sierdogan o a qué Malú esperaremos
entonces la respuesta a esa pregunta